Welcome to the video on
implicit differentiation.
Let's just explain the
difference between implicit
and explicit first.
So if I had a function that
was, let's say, y is equal to
x squared plus 2x plus 3.
In this situation, y, the
variable y, is defined
explicitly in terms of x.
How do I know that?
Well, if you give me an x, I
can just input it into this
expression right there,
and I explicitly get y.
Right?
It just pops out
of the equation.
But on the other hand, what if
I had something like this.
What if I had x squared plus
y squared is equal to 100.
Well now, if I give you an x,
you still can figure out a y,
but it's just not as easy.
Right?
If I said, x is equal to, I
don't know, x is equal to 9,
you would put 9 in here, you
would get 81, plus y squared is
equal to 100, you'd subtract
that, you'd get y squared
is equal to, what, 19?
Those numbers are weird.
And then you'd get y is
equal to the plus or
minus square root of 19.
So you still could solve for
y, but this expression right
here, or this equation,
defines y implicitly.
And that's a different, you
know, when people use the
word explicit or implicit
in everyday language,
it's the same thing.
When you say, he
explicitly said this,
it means, I am hungry.
I explicitly stated
that I'm hungry.
But you could implicitly
state that you're hungry.
You could say, oh well, you
know, I haven't eaten for a
long time, and you know, boy,
it would be nice to maybe eat
something, and that would
be kind of an implicit
expression of your hunger.
Because someone would have to
kind of do a little bit of work
to come to the conclusion that
you're hungry, instead
of you telling them.
So with that out of the
way, let's actually do
some differentiation.
So everything you've learned
about differentiation right
now has been explicit
differentiation.
So example.
For this function, we know
how to take the explicit
derivative here.
Well, it's an explicitly
defined function, so we
just take the derivative.
We apply the
derivative operator.
We take the rate of change of
both sides of this equation
with respect to x.
You could do it like this.
We're taking the derivative
operator, I know this is
getting messy, we're taking the
derivative operator on that
side, and we're also taking the
derivative operator
on this side.
I didn't plan to write
that there that's
why-- so it happens.
On the left side, the rate
of change at y changes
with respect to x, well
we just write that.
The rate of change of y,
for every small change in
y, what is change in x.
That equals-- and then,
we know how to do this
type of derivative.
This is just a
simple quadratic.
So it equals 2x plus 2 plus 0.
So there.
We just did some explicit
differentiation.
So how do we do the
same thing here?
Well, we're going to
do the same thing.
We're going to apply the
derivative operator to both
sides of this equation.
So let me do that, I'll do
that in a different color.
Let me erase all of this,
too, because this is kind
of obvious things that
you might already know.
Let me erase all of that.
OK, so I'll take the derivative
operator to both sides
of this equation.
So this is no different
than what we did up here.
And as you learned in algebra,
anything you do to one side of
the equation, you have to do to
the other side of the equation.
Otherwise it would no
longer be an equation.
Take the derivative operator--
because we're taking the
derivative with respect to x.
We could've taken it
with respect to y.
x squared plus y squared is
equal to, have to take the
derivative of both
sides, right?
Derivative of 100 with
respect to x, right?
So this equals the derivative
with respect to x, let
me put it in brackets.
I was going to do parentheses,
but I think brackets.
Of x squared, plus the
derivative with respect
to x of y squared.
And what's the derivative
with respect to x of 100?
For every change in x, how
much does this change?
Well, it doesn't change at all.
It's going to stay 100, right?
So this is 0.
The derivative of a constant,
really with respect to any
changing variable,
is going to be 0.
So that was just 0.
And what's the derivative of
x squared with respect to x?
Well, we did that
up here, right?
When we took this derivative,
we just took the derivative
of each of these terms, the
derivative of x squared with
respect to x, that's just 2x.
So we get 2x plus-- now this
term here is where you might
get a little bit confused.
I am taking the derivative of
y squared with respect to x.
So let me take you
[? on the side. ?]
You know you shouldn't do this
every time that you do one of
these implicit differentiation
problems, but I'm doing this
because I want you to
understand what we're doing.
So let's say I just defined g
as equal to y squared, right?
So let's say this was g.
And I want to take
the derivative of g
with respect to x.
So I apply the derivative
operator on both sides of
this, so let me do that.
So the derivative, let me
do a d of x on that side,
d of x on that side.
That's a d, there you go.
So what we get is the
derivative of g with respect to
x is equal to the derivative
with respect to x of y squared.
And so far, we haven't
really done much.
I've just rewrote things.
But what does the
chain rule tell us?
The chain rule tells us that
the derivative, let me
stay in the same color.
I'm always switching colors.
The derivative of any variable
with respect to x, or with
respect to another variable, is
equal to the derivative of g
with respect to y times
the derivative of y
with respect to x.
And if you don't have the full
intuition of the chain rule
yet, there's a couple
of ways to do it.
You know, all of these dg's and
dy's that you see throughout
integral and differential
calculus, all these really mean
are really, really, really,
really, small change in g, a
really, really, really, small
change in y, a really,
really, small change in x.
So you can almost view these,
if you multiply this out, this
really, really small change in
y is the same as this really,
really small change in y.
So these are
essentially fractions.
So you could cancel these out,
and that's why you would get
the change in g with respect to
x, or the derivative of
g with respect to x.
So this is what the
chain rule tells us.
So given that this is what the
chain rule tells us, how does
that help us figuring out this?
Well, we know that the
derivative of g with respect to
x is equal to the derivative
of g with respect to y.
But we already know that
g is equal to y squared.
I just made that definition.
That's where we started from.
So what's the derivative
of g with respect to y?
Well, that's just 2y, right,
just using our derivative
rules, or our polynomial rules,
which hopefully you believe
actually work, because there
are several videos
where we prove it.
And then, times the derivative
of y with respect to x.
Which we don't know, and that's
actually kind of what we're
going to try to solve for.
So the derivative of g with
respect to x is 2y times
the derivative of y
with respect to x.
Well, g is just the same
thing is y squared, right?
So the derivative
of, this is g.
And normally when you do this,
you don't have to go through
the whole problem of
substituting for g.
I just wanted to give
you that intuition.
So what's this
derivative right here?
Well, it's going to be the
derivative of this expression
with respect to y, from the
chain rule, so that's 2y.
Times the derivative of y with
respect to x is equal to 0.
When you do it mechanically,
it's actually quite simple.
You just say, oh, well, let me
pretend like y is like an x,
take a derivative, and
I multiply it times
the derivative of y
with respect to x.
Mechanically it's very simple,
but I really want you to
understand that intuition that
this is coming out
of the chain rule.
And actually, the chain
rule itself is not
this bizarre concept.
It's really, you're just
multiplying fractions.
So let me clear up some
space here, and we can
finish this problem.
And then I'll do a problem
where you have to do
implicit differentiation.
And even in this one that I
just gave, it's really useful
to do implicit differentiation.
So let me, I could clear this
guy out up here, clear that
out, clear all of this
stuff out, there we go.
Clear all of that out.
Ready to do some more work.
So now we can solve this
for the derivative of
y with respect to x.
So we get, let's subtract
2x from both sides.
We get 2y dy dx is equal to--
I'm just subtracting 2x
from both sides-- minus 2x.
And then what do we get?
We get dy over dx is equal to,
divide both sides by 2y, the
2's cancel out, you
get minus x over y.
And this is interesting,
just as it is, right?
Because what was this?
This was the equation for a
circle with radius 10, right?
You know, r squared.
And if you know your
trigonometry and all of that,
this tells you that the slope
of a circle, at any point, is
equal to the negative
of x over the y.
Well, we know from trigonometry
that the x is the cosine, and
the y is the sine, and so that
tells you something interesting
about how the derivative is
related to the tangent
and all of that.
But I won't go into that.
We're just learning implicit
differentiation here.
But it's sometimes it's fun
to just think about things.
So how's this different
from everything else
we learned so far?
Well, here we have the
derivative, the derivative is
actually a function of both
the x and the y value.
And if we feel really
uncomfortable having this y
here, if we don't like that,
what we could do, is
we can substitute.
So let's solve for y here.
We get y squared is equal to
100, minus x squared, and then
you get why is equal to the
plus or minus square root
of 100 minus x squared.
So you just substitute
that in here.
Another way of writing
the derivative of y with
respect to x, sometimes
you'll see y prime.
I'm just switching
notation, just so you're
familiar with it.
Is equal to minus x over the
plus or minus square root
of 100 minus x squared.
And to some degree, since we
have plus or minus down here,
this minus sign kind of
doesn't matter, right?
Because when it's a minus here
it becomes a plus, when it's
plus it's minuses, so you
can kind of ignore this.
That's something interesting
for you to think about as well.
Anyway.
And this is interesting,
because our traditional way of
solving derivatives, we had
never seen a plus
or minus here.
So that might be a little
bit interesting to you.
So now let's do a problem
that is actually a bit
of a trick problem.
It's not a trick problem but
it's actually something, that I
think, I first saw it either
when I was practicing for the
AP Calculus exam, or actually
saw it on the AP Calculus exam.
So it's something that
you might encounter.
But it's really neat.
Let's say I have y is
equal to x to the x.
So first, you say,
oh, this looks easy.
Maybe I could use the
power rule, but no.
Chain rule, you have 2 x's
here, and I mean, you might
want to just pause and think
about this for a little bit,
because this actually isn't
that straightforward
of a problem.
And even though right here, y
is explicitly defined in terms
of x, right, if I give you x,
if I say x is 3, well then y
is 3 to the third, y is 27.
So this is an
explicit function.
I explicitly defined
y in terms of x.
But it's very hard to
differentiate explicitly.
And here's the trick.
Let's take the natural log, or
actually you could take any
logarithm, but let's take
the natural log on both
sides of this equation.
So you get the natural log of
y is equal to the natural
log of x to the x.
And why did I do that?
Because now I can use
what we know about
logarithm properties.
We know that log of a to the
b is equal to b log of a.
And you can watch the
exponent properties videos,
if you forgot that.
So let's rewrite this
using this property.
And I'm going to switch colors.
So we get the natural log
of y is equal to x times
the natural log of x.
And now we can implicitly
differentiate this.
So let's take the derivative
with respect to x of both
sides of this equation.
And I'll switch colors again.
d dx.
And I'm writing this just so
you know what I'm doing.
is equal to d dx of
x natural log of x.
So the derivative of this
expression with respect to x is
equal to the derivative of this
expression with respect to y,
times the derivative of
y with respect to x.
So what's the derivative of
this with respect to y?
What's 1/y?
1/y times the derivative, just
the chain rule, the derivative
of y with respect to x.
dy dx is equal to-- and
remember, just mechanically, if
you want to make sure you're
doing it right, you just take
the derivative with respect to
y, and you multiply
it times dy dy.
That's just the chain room.
Equals, and now we take
the derivative of this.
Well, now we can just
use the product rule.
The derivative of
the first, right?
It's this times this.
So what's the derivative of x?
It's 1.
So it's 1 times the natural log
of x plus the derivative of
the second term, 1/x, times
the first term, times x.
Let me clear that out up there.
I'm already over time, but I've
become a YouTube partner,
so my videos can be longer.
But I don't want to make
them too long, because
you'll get bored.
All right.
So let's simplify this.
We get 1/y dy dx is equal to
the natural log of x, plus,
well, that just cancels
out and becomes 1, right?
And so we have the derivative
of y with respect
to x is equal to y.
I'm just multiplying both sides
of this equation times y.
y times the natural
log of x plus 1.
Now, you might say you're done,
but some people just don't like
it, the change of y with
respect to x, they don't like
it being defined in terms of y.
So let's substitute.
We know that y is
equal x to the x.
So that equals x to the x times
the natural log of x plus one.
So another way of saying it is
that y prime, or the change in
y with respect to x, or the
slope at any point of this
curve, is equal to x to the x,
natural log of x,
plus x to the x.
I just distributed
the x to the x.
But that's pretty neat.
This is kind of a, you know, a
five-star problem that you
might see in your books, and
you might see it in a math
competition, and people
will be really impressed.
And they'd be even more
impressed if you kind of
recognized this pattern, and
you're able to find the
antiderivative of it, and
recognize that it
is x to the x.
Anyway, I've talked
for too long.
I will see you in
the next video.